c'est un des cinq été publié sous le
titre faisant l'amour et pas la guerre
donald trump est le leader de la corée
du nord réunis dans un même lit c'est
l'un des dessins réalisés par michael
pour un titre de presse
il présente ce jour-là son métier devant
un parterre de détenus de la maison
d'arrêt de blois
ses sources d'inspiration le monde
contemporain l'émigration l'amour la
violence des thèmes universels comme ici
les dérives du port d'armes aux états
unis je pouffe l'absurde du port des
armes jusqu'à l'extrême ce dr sam
berceau d'un petit on peut imaginer un
bébé america qui se nourrit déjà des
armes sur sur sa tête
les personnes présentes à l'atelier se
prête volontiers au jeu des devinettes
le dessin d'humour ça prend auprès de
tous les publics il ça me touche parce
que c'est une manière de de toucher le
public d'une manière différente
justement c c'est dérisoire et c'est sa
libre service de la pensée donc chacun
est libre de faire ce qu'ils ont envie
et penser ce qu'il veut de ses dessins
et c'est ça qui est bien c'est ouvert au
monde quoi s'est ouvert aux gens sitôt
quitté la maison d'arrêt michael va
devoir plancher sur un dessin pour le
journal le monde
non je me mets une fois que je rentre à
paris dans mon appartement ou ici ça
sera dans la chambre de mon hôtel je
planche
dans la feuille de la page blanche après
une initiation express au dessin les
détenus vont repartir avec leurs
portraits sous le bras signé par l'un
des grands dessinateurs d'humour du
moment
[Musique]